JEN PERSON: Welcome
to "Who's There"
a show about Cloud Identity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the last episode
of "Who's There,"
I talked about why Identity
Platform is awesome
and how to enable it
in your GCP project.
Today, I'm showing you how to
integrate Identity Platform
into your iOS app in Swift.
If you haven't enabled
Identity Platform yet,
I recommend you check out the
last episode of "Who's There"
before proceeding.
You also need an iOS app.
In Xcode, start
with an existing app
or create a new Single View App.
And if iOS isn't in
your jam, then check out
the "Getting Started"
videos for Android or Web,
both linked below.
All right.
With all the prerequisites out
of the way, let's get started.
In the Cloud Console
for my project,
I selected the
Identity Platform tab.
I previously added email
and password authentication.
If you haven't added this yet,
click Add a Provider and Select
email/password.
There are lots of other
providers to explore,
but with today I'm just
sticking with this one.
On this Providers
page, you see a link
in the upper right for
Application Setup details.
This pops up a window with brief
Getting Started information.
When I click the iOS tab, I
see "To get started with iOS,
you'll need to register it
and add Firebase configuration
to your app.
Learn more."
I click Get Started with
Firebase, which takes me
to an entirely new console.
Some of the information is
the same as the Cloud Console,
like project name and
ID, but then there
are all these new tabs down the
side that say Develop, Quality,
Analytics, and Grow, and the
big pop-up in the middle asking
about data sharing.
If you've used Firebase before,
this probably looks familiar.
But it's entirely possible
you've never even heard
of Firebase, let alone used it.
Let's talk about
what's going on here.
Firebase is a suite of products
to help you build your app
and grow your user base.
It includes SDKs for
Objective-C and Swift
for iOS, Java and Kotlin for
Android, JavaScript for Web,
as well as several
frameworks, like Angular.
There are specific for game
SDKs for Unity and C++,
and so much more.
In fact, I can make a
whole series of videos
just on Firebase.
But fortunately, the Firebase
team has already done that.
If you're interested
in finding out more
about any of these
SDKs, check out
the documentation and the
Firebase YouTube channel,
both linked below.
Now, in many ways, Firebase
is the perfect complement
to Google Cloud.
Very broadly speaking,
Google Cloud products
focus on server-side
solutions, like
App Engine, Compute Engine,
Cloud Functions, Kubernetes
Engine, and Cloud Run.
And Firebase products focus
on client-side solutions,
like authentication, cloud
messaging, Cloud Storage
for Firebase, and so on.
I admit that it's
challenging to pin down
the relationship between
Google Cloud and Firebase.
So my oversimplified
explanation is
that Firebase is the way
to access some Google Cloud
Platform products from
a client application.
Specifically for
Identity Platform,
this explanation works well.
The Firebase Auth
SDKs enable you
to access Identity
Platform functionality
from your client app.
With that in mind, let's head
back to that Firebase console.
The Firebase console
automatically
opened to our project.
Notice this UI indicates
that quickstart is already
a Firebase project.
When adding Identity Platform
to a Google Cloud project,
a Firebase project is
automatically created.
First, let's deal
with this pop-up.
It's up to you whether
you want to check off
to use the default settings
for Google Analytics data
or select Do This Later.
Some Firebase products depend
on analytics, like A/B testing.
So if you decide to
incorporate other features,
you probably want
to enable this.
Again, it's up to you.
When you click on
the Project settings,
notice the settings
are identical to
the quickstart Cloud project.
Firebase has basically
added some more details
and functionality to
the cloud project,
similar to when
you enable an API
or add software from
the marketplace.
Since you want to add Identity
Platform to an iOS app,
select Add App, iOS.
This gives you a window with
a series of steps to follow.
Keep in mind that the bundle
ID you choose needs to match
the bundle ID of your iOS app.
The app nickname is
totally up to you.
I won't provide an App Store
ID, since I don't have one yet.
But if you do have one,
feel free to add it here
before creating the app.
I'm now prompted to download a
GoogleService-Info.plist file.
This file informs my iOS
app about my Firebase app,
so I can interface
with Firebase products.
Once downloaded, add
this to your iOS project.
Click Next in the console,
and it gives the next step.
Add the desired pods.
So I will be using CocoaPods to
add the required dependencies,
but you can add the required
code without CocoaPods.
Check out the guide
linked below to find out
how to install the
SDKs without CocoaPods.
OK.
Initialize a new pod
file and then open it.
Add the Firebase/Auth dependency
and then Save the pod file.
Close Xcode to prevent strange
behaviors that can rarely
happen when running CocoaPods
while the project is open.
Then run Pod Install.
Open the created xcworkspace.
All right.
In the project, in
AppDelegate, Import Firebase.
This smart import will only
import the dependencies
you need, so you don't really
have to import Firebase/Auth
specifically, for example.
In the
didFinishLaunchingWithOptions
function, initialize
the Firebase app
using FirebaseApp.configure.
This initializes the Firebase
app using the settings provided
by the
GoogleService-Info.plist file.
OK.
You can now use the
Firebase/Auth SDK
to sign up, clock
in, log out, and get
user info about an
Identity Platform user.
Identity Platform gives you
access to many different login
providers, including federated
identity providers like Google,
Facebook, and Twitter.
You can enable several
login methods for an app,
allowing your users
to authenticate
the way that they prefer.
Some login methods may
require additional steps,
which are listed in the console
when you enable that login
method.
See the documentation
below for information
on how to implement
other login providers.
For now, let's get back to
implementing email and password
login.
Back in the Cloud Console,
create a fake user
with a test email
and a test password.
Of course, you can also create
a new user from the client,
but this is a good way to get us
up and running really quickly.
See how to create
a user in your iOS
app following the link below.
Back in your iOS app in
Xcode, go to the viewDidLoad
for your ViewController.
Call Auth.auth.signIn, and pass
the email and password you just
created in the console.
This function passes
a completion handler
with two parameters--
an optional AuthDataResult
and an optional Error.
AuthDataResult is the result
of sign-in requests containing
both the user and some
additional user info.
First, I check that
AuthDataResult has a value.
And if it doesn't,
log the error.
Otherwise, I can do whatever
I need to do with the user.
Right now, I'll just
log that user's UID.
Now, of course, my
example thus far
is not a complete auth solution.
You need a way for users
to create accounts, handle
password resets, and log out.
Each of these functions needs
some UI development as well.
If you prefer, you can write
all this functionality yourself
using the Firebase SDKs.
The related documentation
is linked below.
But you also have the option to
use the FirebaseAuthUI module.
This open-source UI was created
by auth specialists at Google,
includes all of
the views you would
need to create an account,
log in, log out, and reset
password, which
you can incorporate
in just a few lines of code.
And you can override the
ViewController classes
to change the appearance
of your login.
Whether you make your own
UI or use Firebase UI,
you will very likely need a
way to know the auth status
before programming
any app actions.
For example, you're
going to want
to check if there's
a user logged in
before writing to the database.
That's where Firebase Auth
Listener comes into play.
Let's look at how
to implement it.
I create a function I'm
calling listenForAuthChanges.
In this function, I
call Auth.auth.addSta
teChangeListener.
This function passes a
closure with an optional user
and optional error.
Handle the error
if one is found,
then do what you
need with this user,
like assign the value
of a class's user
to the logged in user.
For the purpose of this example,
I'll just log the user email.
Then I'm actually
going to log out,
so you can see the
StateChangeListener closure
be triggered again.
I put the code to log out in the
separate function here called
logOut.
I run the app, and
the console logs
show that the user is locked
in and then logged out.
Congratulations.
You just added Identity
Platform to an iOS app.
Ready to see what else
Identity Platform can do?
Check out the Firebase Auth iOS
guides, Auth quickstart code,
and the Firebase
YouTube channel.
And be sure to subscribe to the
Google Cloud Platform channel,
so you can be the first to
know about new videos in this
"Who's There" series.
Thanks for watching.
And I'll see you on
the next episode.
[MUSIC PLAYING]